ça c'est presque dans les deux contours
n'est-ce pas se cache souvent
des bobettes
voilà on est prêt pour l'accrochage
[Musique]
je suis ingénieur mais je suis aussi
responsable du bureau de développement
durable à Polytechnique Montréal
le génie ça devrait selon moi est aussi
l'utilisation la plus efficace de toutes
les ressources inventer des nouvelles
choses ça peut être de porter un regard
neuf sur des choses qui existaient déjà
la corde à linge est un peu ça
l'hiver j'étais pas tous les morceaux
c'est quand même froid sur les mains
mais il y a des choses que j'aime
vraiment mettre sur la corde parce que
ça sent tellement bon c'est une
technologie douce une technologie qui
consomme pas grand chose la corde à
linge les démocratiques elle est
disponible pour tout le monde puis pour
moi c'est vraiment un moment
je suis dehors regardez le magnifique
paysage
une poésie dans l'organisation des
vêtements
le tout temps on a utilisé l'air libre
puis le soleil pour faire sécher des
choses utiliser maintenant un fil avec
des poulies qui facilite l'utilisation
de ça c'était une innovation donc des
séchoirs à linge il y en a de toutes
sortes donc on est on continue à être
dans l'innovation plutôt pas besoin
d'être remplacé je pense pas qu'on va se
mettre à faire sécher nos vêtements au
placement non plus
innovation avec récent
ma machine à café
[Musique]
c'est pas plus je peux prête à la
remplacer par un monstre qui va être
gros comme ça qui va avoir l'air que je
vais devoir reprogrammer à chaque fois
je manque d'électricité qui va crier
contre le café est prêt c'est comme trop
technologie c'est pas nécessaire c'est
beaucoup de matériaux c'est des pièces
électroniques ça brise j'aime les choses
qui sont plus
disons facile
à réparer puis à opérer
j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment les il
y a un grand engouement pour que les
choses soient vraiment toute technologie
peu importe la taille de ton terrain les
gens veulent une tondeuse électrique
veulent un souffleur à feuilles veulent
un coupe-bordure c'est pas nécessaire
compte tenu de leur utilisation ou ça
pourrait être partagé puis
malheureusement parfois ce que les gens
vont faire c'est qu'ils vont aller vers
ajouter plus de technologie au lieu
d'ajouter plus de réflexion sur les
besoins en technologie
café à Polytechnique c'est que des
soirées ou des après-midi où les gens
peuvent apporter des objets puis il y a
quelqu'un qui est là pour les réparer
puis leur montrer un peu comment ça se
répare c'est vraiment un moment de
bonheur
ok les gens sortent de là avec un grand
sourire parce que ils ont réussi à ne
pas jeter quelque chose on va prendre la
frontale parce que je vois rien le
véritable progrès d'abord
ça serait la plainissement des
inégalités on peut pas avoir une société
qui est durable quand les riches
deviennent de plus en plus riches puis
les plus démunis en peine à répondre à
leurs besoins et le mental il y a
beaucoup de
composantes sociales pour moi au progrès
des fois dans le développement
technologiques
on se trouve à larguer ceux qui auraient
besoin justement d'une société qui les
soutient donc pour moi ça ce serait le
vrai progrès